Buonasera a tutti Buonasera Io vi vedo
adesso in realtà non vi sento Mi
piacerebbe Magari se possibile come vi
stavo sentendo prima Beh comunque
Insomma Buonasera a tutti Io sono
ovviamente molto contento di partecipare
a questa manifestazione purtroppo
ovviamente meno contento di non esserci
fisicamente però purtroppo adesso sono
giorni un po' un po' complicati Ecco e
fisicamente non non sono riuscito non
sono riuscito ad esserli da voi però o
Grazie dell'invito è io conto se poi
riusciamo intanto col collegamento a
risentirvi
che adesso non sento nulla nel frattempo
Comunque
vi saluto e sono con voi che dire Allora
io sono ovviamente
come troppo gentilmente
anticipato appunto delle presentato
insomma Sì faccio video sulla scuola
sono contento di far ridere su questo
mondo ogni tanto anche Spero riflettere
e di portare Questi spettacoli
incentrati sotto il mondo della scuola
nei teatri
nei teatri veramente di tutta Italia è
stata una stagione molto molto bella e
particolare e fortunata questo questo
invito però che ho accettato con molto
piacere No il fatto di essere qui questa
sera un duplice valore per me perché non
è solamente il video lo spettacolo
divertente solamente dei contenuti che
possono creare più o meno
viralità Ecco diciamo sui sui social ma
è anche soprattutto No il
poterci agganciare qualcosa di più
questo questo festival ha un tema
in particolare che è il tema della
vertigine no ed è un tema che negli
ultimi 300 65 giorni è stato
particolarmente
importante per me perché questo questo
intervento poi tra l'altro mio nello
specifico si chiama Dammi un segno
quindi è qualcosa che voglio raccontarvi
Sperando ovviamente di non di non
buttarla troppo sul patema sul
emozionale ma anche di anzi di renderla
come una storia positiva e propositiva
Tra poco vi spiegherò il perché Dunque
io ho solo laureato in beni culturali
triennale laureati storia dell'arte
magistrale c'è tutt'altro alla Statale
di Milano sono di Lodi abito e vivo a
Lodi e faccio teatro da diversi anni
inizio poi
insegnare a scuola Prima facevo video
sull'università perché quella facevo poi
quando inizio a insegnare vedo che anche
quel mondo il mondo ti chiede all'altra
parte della Barricata della cattedra è
un mondo che merita di essere raccontato
di conseguenza iniziano a raccontare a
questo mondo ma Decido sempre di
continuare a fare comunque questo
mestiere che comunque riempie veramente
il cuore di soddisfazioni l'insegnante
arriva però a un certo punto nella vita
in cui bisogna un pochettino fare i
conti con chi si è davvero io sono molto
molto contento che prima di me ci sia
stato questo intervento pazzesco dove mi
ha particolarmente colpito il pezzo di
questa vita
dritta come questi binari sempre
costanti un giorno identico all'altro
Ecco io quella vita non l'ho mai voluta
ma non perché
valesse meno o di più rispetto a
un'altra semplicemente mi sentivo che
non mi apparteneva sentivo che l'avere
Ogni giorno uguale all'altro non faceva
per me che dovevo provare qualcosa di
più Ora è chiaro che quando si parla di
vertigini nello specifico si parla di
ritrovarsi No in una situazione
potenzialmente pericolosa e vorrei
raccontarvi quanto mi è appunto successo
un anno fa io ero in un'agenzia
un'agenzia di talento sono stato
tantissimi anni ho lavorato molto in
questa agenzia e quindi ricevevo anche
dei compensi veri e propri per il nostro
lavoro Digital e live in più avevo il
lavoro a scuola quindi la mia vita era
strutturata su questi binari sentivo
però che non erano i miei sentivo che
potevo provare a fare davvero la vita
che ho sempre voluto quella dell'attore
e quindi decido un giorno di fine giugno
di lasciare la scuola lasciare l'agenzia
avevo Zero date a teatro davanti e dire
o lavà o la spacca questo è il momento
in cui devo provare il tutto e per tutto
e questo è stato il momento della
vertigine vi ho già detto questo
intervento si chiama Dammi un segno che
è un po' il finale poi di quanto sto per
dire Però all'inizio è stato proprio la
vertigine immaginatevi la gioia di
quando vado a dire a mio padre dirigente
scolastico
ex insegnante che è entrato a scuola a
27 anni cioè tuttora che ne ha 63 gli
dico papà lui insegnante preside mia
mamma medico anestesista mia sorella
farmacista gli dico Papà voglio mollare
tutto e fare i video su Tik Tok è stato
una gioia proprio regalato una gioia
alla famiglia incredibile però ha detto
guarda sarà pure
un momento di vertigine ma sono sicuro
che questa è la strada loro non mi hanno
né ostacolato né supportato Insomma mi
hanno detto Vediamo vediamo un po' che
cosa succede e quello è stato un momento
molto tosto molto duro ora raccontarlo a
distanza su uno schermo in qualche
minuto ovviamente non rende non rende
bene l'idea però vi assicuro che
riallacciandomi un po' anche
l'intervento di prima è stato qualcosa
di particolarmente no particolarmente
importante e impegnativo per me ma io
non voglio raccontare la mia storia per
dire quanto sono stato fortunato quanto
Insomma abbia lavorato a un progetto ma
per dire come La banalità della frase Se
ci credi veramente può succedere sia
importante è una banalità una frase da
bacio Perugina la si legge in ogni Meme
in ogni Social possibile ma quanto è
importante crederci in quello che si fa
bene è fondamentale perché passano i
mesi giugno luglio agosto si prova
organizzarmi i video vanno bene Andate
ne arrivava un po' che non mi ero
strutturato volevo prendere la mia prima
assistente Insomma vedevo che la cosa
non andava molto e dicevo qua ci vuole
un segno veramente un segno un qualcosa
che possa farmi capire quanto la mia
vita è uno sia uno Sliding Doors in
questo momento quanto io posso rimanere
un insegnante con tutta la passione del
mondo oppure provare a fare l'attore che
è quello che ho sempre voluto però
Caspita in maniera veramente
professionale Ecco ero veramente un
video
passano i mesi e mi ritrovo appunto in
questa spiaggia che che si intro spesso
questa spiaggia e mia mamma è venuta a
mancare nel 2015 per questo primo
promesso Spero di non buttarla sul
patema però ecco come dato di fatto
avevo 22 anni mia sorella è 19 nostra
mamma è venuta a mancare quindi insomma
sono stati anni difficili Ho studiato
più per lei che per me e alla fine dico
io parlo pochissimo Insomma di queste
cose però quel pomeriggio ero veramente
disperato ero proprio messo lì a dire
Guardate non ce la fa sono sforzo Ho
fatto una cazzata forse devo rientrare a
scuola forse ho sbagliato tutto forse
ridono funzionano e dico mamma
se veramente devo fare questo mestiere
Se Devo crederci se devo dare tutto in
me stesso qualsiasi Dammi un segno
qualsiasi segno non lo so però per me
non è un gioco è in gioco la vita il mio
momento più alto di vertigini quando
sono stato appunto invitato a questa
splendida manifestazione è stato il dire
Quale può essere stato io non ho dubbi
che sia stato quel pomeriggio è stato
Dammi un segno veramente qualsiasi segno
poi uno può crederci non crederci non è
importante ma quel momento è stato
fondamentale per me perché torno a casa
appoggio il telefono vado in doccia esco
e io che non avevo mai fatto un film in
vita mia e l'obiettivo finale di tutto
il mio lavoro sui social a teatro e
quant'altro È sempre quello di poter poi
andare al cinema ricevo 10 minuti dopo
quel desiderio la chiamata di un mio
carissimo amico che sicuramente
conoscere te a Roberto Lipari che mi
dice vi puzza Vedo allora sto facendo il
mio nuovo film vorrei che tu facessi una
parte
metto giù la telefonate dico Ok andrà
come andrà sarà una vita
pazzesca incredibile alti e bassi Chi lo
può sapere Ma questo era il segno che
volevo questo è il momento in cui la
vertigine non è più appunto paura di
cadere ma da questo momento deve essere
solo voglia di volare questo è stato per
me il massimo è stato il momento più
Scusatemi più emozionante quello in cui
ho veramente capito
quanto la vertigine sia sempre stato
solo uno stato d'animo per me quanto
veramente solo
davanti alla stessa situazione basta
cambiare il punto di vista per rendere
un'opportunità un problema e smetterla
di vedere problemi nelle opportunità
altra frase forse banale forse già
sentite risentita Ma che a me ha aiutato
molto a strutturarmi ha aiutato molto
avere un metodo e quindi se dovessi
proprio scegliere il momento più alto
della mia vertigine quando è poi
diventato invece la più grande voglia di
volare è stato proprio questo sono molto
molto contento di poterlo condividere di
averlo potuto condividere con voi questa
sera purtroppo a distanza ma spero vi
abbia comunque fatto un grande piacere